et notre invité politique c'est
Jean-Christophe Lagarde bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous député de la
Seine-Saint-Denis on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale bonjour
Florent buisson de la République du
Centre merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
Florent
[Musique]
la France
du Mali retraite de leur soldats après 9
ans de lutte contre les djihadistes sur
le terrain c'était une bonne décision
pour vous d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
surtout une décision contrainte après le
coup d'État de 2020 et le coup d'État
2021 de la gente militaire on a au Mali
un pouvoir qui non seulement illégitime
qui pour se maintenir nourri de façon
éhonter une propagande anti-française
comme si nous étions responsable nous
des carences honteux de l'État malien
qui ne sait plus apporter ni la sécurité
ni la justice ni l'éducation ni la santé
à sa population et notamment dans le
centre et dans le nord du Mali et donc
on a plus rien à faire là-bas enfin on a
plus rien à faire là-bas
si tu es au Mali 5 dans le reste de la
bande sahélienne
à la fois mené une guerre héroïque et
très efficace la seule chose c'est que
c'est pas sur le terrain militaire qu'on
gagne une guerre comme celle-là c'est
sur le terrain politique pourquoi est-ce
que François Hollande avait décidé qu'on
intervenait au Mali c'était pour éviter
l'effondrement des tamaliens
politique souvenez-vous au départ
c'était nous tout seul puis c'était le
G5 Sahel puis ensuite bon ça c'est un
échec et je pense que François Hollande
pour une fois a raison de dire
qu'Emmanuel Macron aurait dû tirer les
conséquences dès 2020 et le coup d'État
au Mali les conséquences plutôt et
redéployer le dispositif français
militairement on est capable de tenir
mais on tient quoi on tient pour un
régime de corrompu pour un régime qui
n'est pas élu pour un régime qui fait
appel à des mercenaires non pas pour
combattre les djihadistes mais pour
opprimer sa population et se maintenir
au pouvoir la France peut pas rester
dans ces conditions
du port du masque mi-mars les conditions
autour d'incidence et au nombre
d'hospitalisation est-ce que c'est un
calendrier qui tombe à pic selon vous
à quelques semaines
sur un plan sanitaire et pas sur un plan
électoral pour vous c'est électoraliste
et moi l'envie du président de la
République de rentrer en campagne je lui
dis pourquoi hier il y a encore 280
morts en France il y a encore 92000
contaminations hier il y a quelques mois
quand il y a 20 mois quand on avait le
problème on était en confinement je ne
dis pas qu'on doit se confiner on a de
la chance pour l'instant le variant au
micro a des conséquences moins graves
mais c'est pas banal 280
donc
l'épidémie décroît alors qu'on est monté
des sommets tout à fait impressionnants
quand même dans la vie sociale
au rythme elle décroît on est un taux de
reproduction de 0,5 ce qui veut dire que
une personne contaminée enfin il faut
deux personnes contaminées qui contamine
une seule derrière ça diminue de moitié
à peu près on peut imaginer que mi mars
ça soit plus simple et puis après on
sait que les beaux jours revenant on
aura une période
mais qu'on nous disait depuis 15 jours 3
semaines que c'était au début mars qu'il
fallait faire parce que début mars il se
trouve le 4 mars c'est le début de la
campagne présidentielle officielle voilà
c'est là où je dis
je préfère je préfère l'expression de
Monsieur Véran hier 10 ans quand on
arrive à se raisonnable dans nos
hôpitaux parce que c'est ça la ligne à
ce que j'entendais dans la bouche du
Premier ministre dans l'entourage du
président de la République vous
inquiétez pas on va vous alléger
histoire vous soyez le bonne humeur
et 2022 la dette publique devrait
s'accroître de 560 milliards est-ce que
Manuel
quand on a eu la ré brutale de
l'économie il fallait effectivement que
l'État interviennent pour aider les
entreprises pour aider les personnes
pour aider pourquoi parce que si l'état
d'intervenait pas pour ça vous perdez à
la fois des entreprises donc des
contribuables de demain et vous aviez
des chômeurs qu'il fallait indemniser
tout de suite et demain bon évidemment
qu'il fallait le faire ce qui par contre
deuxièmement est parfaitement
irresponsable de la part d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est quelle heure que les autres
pays les Allemands les Italiens avec
Mario Draghi joue pas rappelle qu'on
partage la même monnaie on rétablit
l'équilibre de leur compte nous cette
année on laisse filer vous oubliez tout
ce qui est commune que je ne conteste
pas
exactement
mais je vais le dire maintenant j'espère
que vous me réinviterez au mois de
juillet la récréation va se terminer
très vite parce que 9 milliards
la vie va devoir se serrer d'abord parce
que les chanceliers
on est en train de parler de la Cour des
comptes le chancelier allemand qui a
rétabli ses comptes va pas accéder que
la France continuait à payer à son
crédit à lui bon et donc les promesses
de l'élection présidentielle qui
explique quand même qu'on doit contenir
la dette que ça suffit et que il y a des
réformes à faire par exemple en
diminuant un certain nombre de fonctions
publiques qui sont les fonctions de
statistiques en les décentralisant vers
les régions ce qui fait qu'on aura
besoin de moins de monde parce qu'on
voit bien que dans les collectivités
locales il y a pas
en embauchant des fonctionnaires 50000
dans les fonctions
de la République un tour de vie
obligatoire budgétaire à partir
de l'argent magique avant les élections
ils viennent vous faire les poches après
moi je préfère comme Valérie Pécresse
quelqu'un qui vous dit il y a des
réformes structurelles à faire sur les
retraites parce que ça permet des
économies il faut diminuer la fonction
publique qui est d'administration de
papier mais il faut réinvestir dans
celle des fonctions publiques
régaliennes c'est la sécurité c'est la
santé c'est l'éducation nationale voilà
c'est il vaut mieux dire la vérité aux
gens avant pour éviter qu'il pleure
après est-ce que les Français entendent
toujours la vérité avant malheureusement
pas souvent
d'EDF à hauteur de plus de 2 milliards
d'euros pour aider EDF qui doit faire
face à une production nucléaire et pour
aider EDF face à la mesure prise par le
gouvernement de demande à EDF de vendre
l'électricité à bas coût à ses
concurrents
on a décidé le gouvernement a décidé
pour éviter avant les élections
l'augmentation des prix de l'électricité
de fixer de figer le prix d'accord 8
milliards et là on récapitalise de
demi-heure et
demi-heure et demi sur vos impôts bah
voilà et on nous a déjà fait le coup je
vais revenir et puis après les élections
bah il y aura toute façon augmentation
du prix de l'électricité parce que il y
a une autorité de régulation des prix de
l'énergie et elle va intervenir à trop
tard pour l'élection c'est leur astuce
enfin ça a déjà coûté rassurez-vous le
reste de la facture arrive sur le prix
de l'électricité le plus simple UTT
comme nous le proposons comme Valérie
Pécresse le propose qu'on baisse les
taxes sur l'électricité qui aurait
permis d'avoir effectivement de contenir
durablement sans mettre de F en
difficulté
mais bien sûr
quand on nous a dit on vous supprime la
taxe d'habitation par quoi il le
financer il y avait 10 milliards de
suppression de taxe d'habitation 10
milliards d'augmentation des prix de
l'essence ça a donné les gilets jaunes
le pouvoir de Monsieur Macron c'est le
mensonge permanent
aujourd'hui dans dans les transports
franciliens
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce
mouvement
en fait il est illustre la tension qui
va exister qui existe et qui va exister
dans notre pays sur l'inflation
l'inflation est repartie je ne crois pas
qu'elle soit momentanée il faut arriver
à la contenir ça veut dire que les prix
augmentent et donc il va y avoir une
demande d'augmentation de salaire dans
certains secteurs c'est supportable et
justifié je pense par exemple et le
patron m'a le voir à la restauration à
un certain nombre dans le bâtiment aussi
d'ailleurs il ne trouve pas les salariés
un problème de formation mais il y a
aussi un problème de rémunération je
vous rappelle qu'une des raisons pour
laquelle Valérie Pécresse propose qu'on
augmente de 10 % des salaires sur la
durée du quinquennat 3 % des 202210 sur
la durée du quinquennat c'est justement
parce que on tient bien compte du fait
que travailler ça doit permettre de
vivre parce que sinon il y a quelque
chose qui va pas pour la RATP
l'entreprise fait environ 130 millions
de bénéfices sur le groupe 130 millions
de bénéfices chaque année si ces agents
doivent être mieux rémunérés ça doit pas
mettre en entreprise en difficulté mais
je pense qu'il y a une marge de
négociation que l'entreprise devrait
utiliser parce que elle est pas obligé
de faire
et donc je pense qu'il y a une
possibilité d'augmenter le personnel
parce qu'il rame parce qu'il galère
parce que comme tout le monde le plein
d'essence la facture de gaz électricité
l'alimentation est en train d'augmenter
tant qu'on peut le faire sans mettre
l'entreprise en difficulté je trouve que
je serai normal j'aimerais bien
d'ailleurs que quand on a ce genre de
relation on puisse discuter avant la
grève parfois sont les syndicats qui
refusent de discuter avant la grève
parfois c'est l'entreprise c'est plus
simple de se mettre autour de la table
que de perturber tout le monde y compris
votre propre émission parce que je
pouvais pas arriver à l'heure
Valérie Pécresse sans condition est-ce
qu'après le meeting de dimanche il y a
chez vous quelques interrogations voir
quelques doutes il y a eu une discussion
clairement après le meeting de dimanche
mais vous avez une discussion franche
oui bien sûr
je vais pas réveiller mes conversations
mais je vais vous dire deux choses la
première c'est qu'il faut pas rigoler
personne ne va faire passer Valérie
Pécresse pour quelqu'un de raciste et
cetera elle a toujours demandé de sortir
des thèmes de l'extrême droite les mots
des mots parce que je pense que quand
elle n'est pas raciste tout le monde le
sait elle combat le racisme depuis des
années elle est parfaitement
républicaine elle est exactement dans la
ligne de Jacques Chirac il faut pas la
faire passer pour ce qu'elle est pas en
revanche je pense qu'il y a une
maladresse dans ce discours c'est quand
on utilise les mots de l'adversaire
soit c'est pour les dénoncer clairement
comme elle l'a fait à France 2 et fort
heureusement soit vous tombez dans le
piège c'est à dire que grosso modo vous
alimentez leur truc il y a pas de grands
remplacement en France c'est un mensonge
ça n'existe pas
été utilisé pour déformer ce qu'elle
disait parce que vous savez dans le même
temps sur le discours quand elle de la
nécessité de décentraliser notre pays
pour être plus efficace écouter moins
cher quand elle parle de redonner une
chance à travers l'éducation alors que
s'il y a un des classements dans
d'autres pays c'est le déclassement
éducatif depuis 30 ans et on a besoin
que les gamins de la République ils ont
une chance de réussir quel que soit leur
milieu social c'est l'école qui leur
donne ça quand elle ouvre de nouvelles
solidarités pour les femmes seules pour
les personnes handicapées on n'est pas
du tout sur la caricature du discours
que ça a donné c'est cette erreur de
communication cette utilisation
contrairement à monsieur Zemmour qui est
comment dirais-je fait preuve de racisme
assumé multi condamné ou à Madame le
penché bon quand elle explique pour être
français
[Musique]
peux pas vraiment assimiler sa maison
de la France et la tradition de la
République et j'en suis très heureux
comme ça quand vous êtes en France qu'on
vous a fait venir en France ou qu'on
vous a accepté en France l'ambition de
notre nation depuis toujours depuis la
révolution c'est de vous donner envie
d'être français et vous êtes français
dès lors que vous aimez la France vous
en respecter les valeurs et que vous
adhérez à ces valeurs
Sarkozy c'était 40 milliards d'euros
investi dans les quartiers ghetto Izé de
la de la République française monsieur
Macron c'est 6 milliards et peut-être
je suis à Public Sénat aujourd'hui quand
on dit en 6e un gamin qui sait pas qu'on
correctement lire écrire et compter pour
faire simple c'est quand même 20 % de
nos gamins ou en mathématiques ou en
français un peu plus d'ailleurs
c'est Laurent Lafont le président de la
commission éducation et culture au Sénat
on a participé décentralisé la santé
c'est-à-dire donner de la démocratie au
niveau régional on a vu ce qui s'est
passé pendant la crise enfin c'est les
régions
je préfère des régions efficaces et
surtout sous la responsabilité des élus
parce que moi j'aimerais bien quand on
vote au moment des régionales pouvoir
juger la façon dont la sorte de la santé
est organisée
le lien entre mon médecin de ville et
l'hôpital est organisé comment on lutte
contre les déserts médicaux bon ben vous
voyez dans le programme je pourrais en
citer bien d'autres naturellement on y a
participé est-ce que c'est le programme
que j'aurais présenté si j'avais été
candidat à l'élection présidentielle non
est-ce que c'est le plus proche de ce
que peuvent penser des gens du centre et
de centre droit qui comme nous sont
attachés à la fois à la construction
par exemple ou d'autres représentants de
cette première
élection présidentielle et je l'ai déjà
dit c'est tous les sujets est-ce que la
France a un problème d'immigration de
sécurité d'autorité de la réponse est
oui est-ce que c'est le seul problème de
la France la réponse est malheureusement
non parce que si on avait que ça comme
problème et donc le reste de la campagne
doit être consacré non pas à parler de
ce qui se passait ou de leur débattre il
y a 3 mois c'est en tout cas ce que je
recommande à Valérie Pécresse et je
crois ce qu'elle a commencé à faire mais
elle doit parler de la façon dont on
intègre nos jeunes de la façon dont on
équilibre d'ailleurs
l'absence de candidature de Monsieur
Macron pour l'instant c'est hypocrisie
qui fait que le principal acteur de
l'élection présidentielle il est quand
même président de la République ils
prive les Français
[Musique]
mais c'est ça qui pose une réelle
difficulté c'est que les Français ne
rentreront pas dans la campagne tant
qu'il fera semblant de pas être candidat
pendant que c'est 12h30
mais surtout je débattrai pas avec mes
concurrents c'est encore de la
démocratie justement sur Emmanuel Macron
peut-être une précision politique pour
nos téléspectateurs aujourd'hui
politiquement qu'est-ce qui différencie
votre partie de l'aile droite de la
macronie ou bien encore d'horizon de
d'Édouard Philippe pour qu'on comprenne
bien
c'est pas compliqué on vient de vivre 5
ans sur lequel il n'y a eu aucune
avancée européenne malgré les discours
aucune sur lequel on a vu une présidence
verticale n'ayant toute possibilité de
contracter avec la société les syndicats
on leur parle pas le Parlement on sait
pas ce que c'est les associations on
veut pas en entendre parler un
autoritarisme vertical Jupiter rien qui
est le contraire même de ce que nous
croyons de la société nous pensons qu'il
faut largement décentraliser
contractualisé faire confiance à la
société parce que les acteurs sont plus
mobiles intelligents adaptatif que cette
espèce de pouvoir engoncé dans sa
certitude de n'être que lui d'avoir
raison la réindustrialisation française
elle n'a pas été amorcée contrairement à
ce qu'on nous raconte je vous prends un
exemple puisqu'on parle de DF et du
nucléaire l'incohérence
aujourd'hui nous explique qu'il faut
faire l'inverse en 5 ans et sur le
nucléaire c'est pire voilà un président
de la République qui a 2 ans et demi a
laissé voter à l'Assemblée nationale une
loi énergie qui confirme la fermeture je
ne sais plus de 13 ou de 15 centrales
nucléaires et qui arrive à 2 mois de
l'élection présidentielle
vraiment il va falloir construire des
centrales nucléaires
d'énergie nucléaire
chez vous
je vais vous dire si Valérie Pécresse
n'est pas au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle les Français seront pris
dans le piège qu'il redoute depuis 5 ans
que prépare monsieur Macron depuis 5 ans
c'est lui ou c'est l'extrême droite et
bien c'est très dangereux parce que en
l'absence de débat et un président qui
serait réélu par défaut il ne pourra pas
gouverner il n'aura pas légitimité et on
terminera dans une crise sociale
rapidement
c'est-à-dire une assemblée croupion qui
n'a pas le droit de s'exprimer
plus capable
quand il provoque comme le président de
la République actuelle est provocateur
ou quand il méprise les classes
populaires et les classes moyennes ça
crée une tension dans le pays qui est
dangereuse voilà pourquoi je pense qu'il
vaut mieux avoir un vrai choix au second
tour que d'être contraint de voter
Macron pour éviter les Sabres
[Musique]